I've got this instruction booklet,
but that will give me step by step
instructions on how to
build this LEGO model.
You know that it's organized, right?
When you flip through it, you can see
that each step is arranged in order and
there are page numbers to
help you find your place.
All of the instructions
take a common form,
which means that you can easily
jump to any page in the booklet and
figure out exactly what the LEGO
designers want you to build.
This organization is helpful,
it allows you to spend your energy
decipher in exactly what you want to
build rather than just simply
trying to read the booklet.
Frameworks are similar, they help us
manage all of the coding complexity
by giving us places and
patterns for writing it.
Some frameworks have their own set of
conventions on how to name files.,where
to put them and how to get them
interacting with each other.